i don't know what happened to me in the
womb but like i
i can't pay attention to story and games
like i i'm sure there's one or two
people out there who can can sympathize
with me but
the moment story comes on any video game
i'm like where's the skip button where
is it really
i can't i can't pay attention what's
what's your favorite story in a video
game then
[Music]
trick question has there ever been one
bro i need to like really go deep in my
memory i remember the only
game that i think i watched the
cutscenes and i think i was like 15.
i don't even know why i played this game
it's called blue dragon it was a jrpg
weird game two people in the comments
who like i know what that is it's like
it's a jlp comment below if you play
blue dragon it was
it was just seemed like a uh dragon
quest knockoff
but i didn't know what dragon quest was
at the time but i watched dragon quest
afterwards and i was like
wait a second this looks awfully like
that game i used to like
and you know it pains me every time but
when i go to press that skip button yeah
i like that
i don't know what it is like is there
something wrong with me that i can't
enjoy story and video games
i mean i'm sure there's a because right
maybe but like for me it's like i look
for a gameplay loop
not a not a story i'm like i'm like the
complete opposite
well no because you play you've played
league of legends you played it at a
fair amount you played people like
playing right now in terms of like
single-player games yeah like i i
need a story i don't play single-player
games i mean you played
for example cuphead or something yeah
actually speedrun cuphead that was fun
but that was for the gameplay loop
that wasn't for yeah yeah exactly like
like i tried playing cuphead i'm like
why am i playing cuphead
what is the narrative reason for me to
complete this game i just love running
gun games i i i need a narrative reason
and if you
need me to sit through like a two-hour
cut scene i'll [ __ ] do it
if it's if it's if it's a good if it's a
good story i'll [ __ ] do it
like the reason i loved doom 2016 so
much is
you literally start that game you smash
a skull open and you start shooting
i'm like that was like oh my god dude
2016 is the epitome of like
like they made monkey brains they made a
game for me
it was like gun enemies
that was like exactly what i wanted i
just wanted a game
that was like [ __ ] the story let's just
make a like gameplay that is addictive
right yeah and so when i play like
you know what pisses me off to death
about jrpgs i love jrpgs but do you
think the moment
the moment they start making the menu a
[ __ ] challenge
is when i start i'm like this is too
much like i love fire emblem three
houses right but there was times in that
their menuing
was like half of gameplay
you are playing the game on the main
menu yeah but like okay you know
like i i go from i jump from
multiplayer's game to
multiplayer games like i've been like
diamond in league of legends like five
years in a row yeah i
started playing tft recently got to
diamond one and that nearly master tier
if you know if you play these games you
know it's good [ __ ] i'm a big brain
essentials
playing valiant now with gone sometimes
yeah it's a good game to csgo i played
overwatch got to master in that like i
i mean okay what's like your opinion on
like something like the metal gear solid
series then did you ever play
with those games yeah i played your song
i like well because that's like hit very
heavily still
that's like a
[Laughter]
right halo i love halo i have no idea
what any of the stories are about the
moment
i remember like the halo story is great
yeah i remember there was a scene i play
mass effect
no no no no no no too much story for me
i remember i remember halo right i
remember
they like hyped it up the sad ending
like i mean if you don't know that
cortana you know
but she comes back sort of so cortana
dies right
i remember everyone's hyping up dude
because so sad so sad i was playing my
friend and we were doing it together
yeah and the moment the cut scene
happened i [ __ ] skipped it
no no what are you doing like we need to
find out what happens i'm like why we
gotta shoot things
oh this is hurting me so much i don't
know man i just
i'm sure there's one am i in the
minority here uh
i don't know i feel like it's 50 50
right maybe or like seven maybe
maybe i don't know i don't know because
there must be a reason why the most
popular games
are like multiplayer games right yeah it
means they're playing by 11 year olds
you know that
monkey brain yeah monkey brain i mean
the the reason i got into games like
league and vitamin is just because
i could just get into it it's like it
was like a stressful it's a 40 minute
thing that you
do and it's no more it's just it's just
like a it's it's like a different kind
of stress believe in like animal
crossing for example but
you just you just get in a quick session
you get out you play as long as you want
it's a close loop you don't feel like
anything else so like for single player
experiences i wish i
i liked to get invested in a game in the
same way that i like to get invested in
an anime
and like i i love just i love that
feeling of just marathoning a show and
just
getting just putting yourself into a
story and being able to like physically
interact with the story yeah
it's so [ __ ] cool yeah i think i
ruined games for myself
um during the xbox so is there literally
not a single game that you enjoyed the
story of
i cannot like i i enjoyed zelda breath
of the wild a fuckton but i don't know
like what i was doing did you know i
just
remember because when i the while it's
such a good story too
does it the moment we started talking to
nbc i'm like give me the bomb give me
the items
shut the [ __ ] up i need a potion because
dude breath of the wild was the last
game i played where i got like no matter
what
the game was out there that i wanted to
play it yeah like you said it sucked me
in i
loved that game yeah that was because i
felt like the way they built the world
didn't require a story because the story
was the same [ __ ] we're used to it was
not
in bad go but but in my opinion the the
most genius thing about breath of the
wild is that yes
you could skip all of the dialogue and
still really [ __ ] enjoy purely that's
why i loved it because
it's even more enjoyable when you
actually talk to the npcs and especially
the ones that are kind of just out in
the open not the ones that are in the
towns and just hearing what they say
it does such a good job in world
building
i'm serious you're laughing you're
laughing but the npc's like i
i listen to all the npcs and i'm like
okay i have so much of a better
understanding of this wall
joey's like i'm on the visual novel
playthrough i'm hearing this and i'm
like wait you
spoke to the mpc yeah wait when like
okay
the thing i hate the most right is when
games make you speak to npcs
i hate that so much it depends on like
the game for me because if it's a world
i'm not invested in
then i'm like whatever this is this is
this is shitty but if it's like what i'm
super invested in i speak i'm that kind
of person just speaks to everyone
because i want to get as much content as
i can
out of this game yeah exactly